Speaker 1: In the other covid related news,
there are states out there who aren't relying
on the goodwill of people with no goodwill
to get vaccinated.
We're seeing spikes in all across the country,
in Louisiana and Arkansas, Florida, Texas,
where we thought we were, we had a stranglehold
on this thing.
We thought the worst days were behind us.
And Florida's infection rate right now is
approaching the highest levels of the entire
pandemic.
Child hospitalization rates are raising.
It is it is a worrying specter all across
the country, but in certain states, it's worse
in my home state of California, not my home
state, but where I live right now, they are
taking action.
They are mandating now it was just just announced
they are mandating vaccines for health care
workers.
Reading from the L.A. Times, California health
care workers must be vaccinated by the end
of September under new health order in what
officials characterized as the first requirement
of its kind in the nation.
California ordered Thursday that health care
workers statewide must be fully vaccinated
against covid-19 come early fall.
The new mandate applies to employees and hospitals,
skilled nursing facilities, clinics, doctors
offices, hospice facilities, dialysis centers
and most other health care settings and stipulates
that they complete their inoculation regimen
by September 30th.
Quote here from an official As we continue
to see an increase in cases and hospitalizations
due to the Delta variant of covid-19.
It's important that we protect the vulnerable
patients in these settings.
Dr. Thomas, Oregon State public health officer
and director of the California Department
of Public Health, said in a statement.
Today's action will also ensure that health
care workers themselves are protected.
Vaccines are how we end this pandemic.
Reasonable.
This is a reasonable approach and expected
approach, which is miles apart.
It is an alternate universe here in California,
leadership wise relative to Florida.
Or Arkansas, I know the Ferren cousins talked
about it the other day about Asa Hutchinson,
the former senator and now governor of Arkansas,
who's like, oh, I made a huge mistake, y'all.
I shouldn't have signed the ban on Marzook
mandates because now people are dying all
around me.
All my constituents are in a in bad shape.
States like that, rules like that don't apply
in certain states.
California being one of them.
It was just last week the governor, Gavin
Newsom, announced that California health care
employees would soon either have to show proof
of their vaccination status or be subjected
to regular testing.
The new order largely removes the testing
option and allows only limited religious or
medical exemptions from the vaccine requirement.
Employees who are exempted would have to be
tested regularly twice a week if they work
in acute or long term care facilities and
once a week in other health care settings.
Unvaccinated employees would also have to
wear a surgical mask or respirator, such as
in in ninety five while inside a facility.
All of these are reasonable expectations of
the entire populace, but of course they're
reasonable for someone working in a health
care setting.
It is disgraceful the manner with which certain
municipalities, certain states.
Have dealt with this, which is to say not
dealing with it.
To act like this is a liberty issue.
Is nonsense, as I've talked about, if you
choose not to wear a seat belt, you're only
harming yourself.
If you choose not to wear a helmet on a motorcycle,
really, it's it just you that you're going
to harm.
This is not the case with the coronavirus.
If I'm not vaccinated, I am and I have been
for months, but if I'm not and I'm walking
around asymptomatic, just breathe in my filth
all over everybody and I get somebody sick
and they die, that's on me.
It's not about my liberty when I infect someone
and they die and I have encroached upon their
rights.
It's not wearing a helmet, it's not wearing
a seatbelt, it's not much more liberty, all
has nothing to do with that.
It is basic decency and the protection of
our neighbors.